two minutes ago this man was on the
floor but now he's sitting to my right
right here on the Rich Eisen show he's
the chairman of a nerection CEO of
vaynermedia currently subject of the day
levy I mean I could go on and on and on
the garyvee audio experience top 50
global podcast he is none other than
Gary Vaynerchuk how are you bud I'm
amazing I'm sorry I'm late no don't
worry
are you really miss Reed's fault even
your I understood that no we understand
he makes a Bill Clinton look on time so
hey I'm even your sense of positivity is
not is not squelched by the 405 traffic
not even that Gary no I just have you
know empathy for everybody here in the
audience and year like that that was
that was my problem but I I'm I'm a
Jersey boy traffic is like oxygen now
we're in Jersey are you from I grew up
in Edison New Jersey
um and so a lot of Turnpike and Gardens
say Parkway traffic okay sure
so then what exit are you that's you
know that's the phrase 131 you know okay
how did you get started Gary you know
he's born in the former Soviet Union I
would I would say I was an entrepreneur
before it was the cool thing like it is
now lemonade stands baseball cards
my dad eventually dragged me into the
liquor store that he owned and I stocked
shelves and my teenage years I realized
people collected wine that attached to
my you know passion around sports
collecting yes and I launched one of the
first e-commerce wine businesses in
America in 1996 winelibrary.com
how old were you at the time I was 21
and and that's kind of what started
everything to give context because this
you know knowing this show my full
business ambition is to buy the New York
Jets and so at the time I thought I'd
open up the toys-r-us of wines then work
out for Toys R Us so I'm glad I didn't
go down that path but open up 4,000 wine
stores sell the franchise buy the Jets
along the way the dot-com became big
YouTube came out I started a youtube
show it exploded I realized I had
another knack which was what are people
gonna do with technology before other
people knew it led me to becoming an
investor and the first three companies I
invested in were Facebook Twitter and
Tumblr
I've heard of them that worked out
that's giving me a chance to maybe do
this Jets thing uh and then I started
this company called vaynermedia because
I realized that people were wasting
money in marketing on print outdoor
television and not all print not all
outdoor not all television but and by
the way and banner ads on websites and
search just you know I would argue in in
a 20-18 world the 5,000 biggest
advertisers in America or globally for
that matter are probably wasting
somewhere in the ballpark of 80 to 90
cents on the dollar and I became a
historian of what happened between radio
and television transition and so that's
what I've been up to now
Gary Vaynerchuk here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so that that and also I saw
you at the NFL Draft my brother and I
started vaynermedia two years ago he
left we started a Jerry Maguire agency
called Vayner sports mm-hmm and yeah
we're gonna build the biggest sports
agency in the world and so you currently
represent about 15 guys in the NFL we're
NFL only we're looking at eSports and
MBA
you know Braxton Miller Josh Jackson my
paradis on and on and on and so we're
very excited about that world I think
it's right for disruption so what do you
mean by that so for eSports cuz that is
something that is off the charts yep but
a lot of mainstream sports fans
yes we're listening and watching us
right now yeah that's something that
kids do that's something that you know
that it's not I'm not gonna sit down and
watch a video game I mean what what what
do you see for the future of eSports the
1982 NBA Finals was on tape delay in
America mm-hmm that's what I see which
is I don't care what people say now I
know that 36 year old Rick doesn't care
about eSports but the 16 year old
version of him the exact same person
thinks that Ninja is one of the three
best athletes in the world because he's
the best Fortnight player in the world
you know we've seen the ebb and flow
right our great-grandfather's thought
that horse-racing and boxing were the
number one in two sports along with
baseball of the day you know anybody
who's naive and doesn't understand the
ebb and flow of the favorite sports of
our culture eSports is out the bag like
twitches like dominating it's here it's
real and over to the next 20 30 years it
will be a top four sport
do you think the current conventional
top for sports Gary Vaynerchuk right now
have a millennial problem I think
baseball and hockey potentially do I
think that the NBA is dominating and I
think the NFL you know and we spend a
lot of time in the sports world talking
about this is still kind of like just
the limited nature of games right like
TJ's gonna lose his mind if the if the
Cowboys lose the first two games of the
year there's only 16 of them just a
limited nature of that sport I think
we'll hold it strong but your point
you're pointing to Rich Eisen show
social media yeah an extraordinary TJ
Jeffers yes how old are you TJ he's up
there rich by the way has he sat in this
seat and talked about wrestling because
his knowledge is deep and the world
needs to hear it well that I agree okay
okay but we do have the platform to do
that but I guess my point is is if Bryce
Harper walk down Main Street anywhere in
the US right now literally Pryce Harper
was walking naked through Broadway right
now a lot of people wouldn't know it's
him that's a BAM baseball wants to
monetize every digital asset problem and
that's a problem because we're not you
have to build up the athlete right and
trout and Harper and Kershaw don't get
enough commercials and if the contents
not living on YouTube and Instagram
outside of the MLB Network there's a
problem well what did you see the video
on oK you've been traveling the world
did you see the video Terry Collins that
got out there there now do you see the
okay where it would meet Major League
Baseball had Terry Collins watch with
the the former Mets manager this is a
year old you could hear it on the
microphone picked up by the major league
baseball umpire somebody leaked it it
was when Collins got thrown out it was
very profane you could hear the umpire
talking about how maybe he was in
trouble with major league baseball just
know what was going on if he if he
didn't throw him and his pitcher out for
throw him behind somebody and baseball
yanked that off the off the internet
because they had a deal with the major
league baseball umpires yep to not get
it out there do you think that's the
sort of stuff that maybe sports league
should be allowing out there despite
what it might mean for I think it's
weird I made the TJ reference back to
wrestling I think all sports need to
take a page out of Vince McMahon's
playbook and actually build up these
personalities
all costs at all costs like I am the
fact that Jesus fish you stir is
dramatically more culturally relevant
than all of the baseball all-stars
combined is a baseball problem the end
wretch like this is about attention this
is back to my guy Joe Namath
this is like Sonny made Joe Namath a
celebrity and that drove it and so this
is celebrity culture and the ESPN's and
the barstools and this show and and
social media all this this is all about
attention arbitrage and we live in a new
world and hockey and baseball are
looking backwards for short term
economics the NBA Adam Silver is
dominating these other commissioners
laughing at them probably in his sleep
and the NFL's just like this big
conglomerate 16 games we'll listen if
the NHL goes to 16 games it's a top
floor sporting like look at the World
Cup right like people can't like by the
way while we're filming right now like
you know I'm so pumped Germany's out
this is just random to sense for like
South Korea punching Germany in the
mouth is about as delicious of a flavor
as I could taste this morning I'm very
and Brazil just scored while we just
chatted well we were talking about
Millennials Gary Vaynerchuk entrepreneur
multiple best-selling author New York
Times bestseller list etc etc here on
the Rich Eisen show so Namath was your
guy Eric Godfrey went outside 19 kids
everybody listening this is how we did
in 82 you moved to neighborhood your mom
throws you outside for 10 hours and you
find friends it was very wrong that's
how we did it
I mean I don't think kids know what the
world used to be I went outside there's
three kids throwing a Nerf ball green
and white they asked me what my favorite
football team is I'm just learning how
to speak English at this point rich you
know because I wasn't born here I'm go I
don't know they're like you're a Jets
fan
it's the 82 season yeah the Jets go to
the AFC Championship game that's I think
I've got this figured out look if we got
a little shot of you up there it's you
with your bro come on yeah yeah look I
was a Jets and Yankees fan which was a
Jersey combo right the wonder we get
so well that's me too and so uh and you
know I'm an 80s baby though so all I had
was Mattingly I of course grew up the
one year of the Mets were better than
the Yankees right there's another weird
thing with me from a fandom standpoint
though the Yankees and Rangers both won
championships for me in 94 96 and I
basically checked out I'm now fully
all-in just jets and Knicks tie I care
about the climb sued jets and Knicks I
mean you're what do you think of Dolan
yeah I think he's - I don't think he's a
good owner I don't you know I don't
III don't think Dolan's a good owner I
don't think so either you know Wow can
you buy the Knicks first can you do that
you know I mean you still have to amass
a lot of wealth so I'm working here but
it's gonna come down to timing of death
me owning the Jets or Nyx's being
completely predicated on the Dolans or
Johnson's dying you know so I don't know
if I can track him rich while I have you
and I know so many can we talk about
bandwagon fans can we just segue here
let's hold on let's let's let's let's
take a break here okay you know let's go
to multiple one final segment oh gosh at
garyvee on Twitter Instagram etc we're
back with Gary Vaynerchuk going all in
on on on Fairweather fans when we come
back here
[Music]
gary vaynerchuk here on the Rich Eisen
show Wow where do we go first
let's stick on bandwagon okay the radios
back right radio okay so it might have
missed your your it's very signal
I need radio audience listen I need
Rich's help because he has a enormous
amount of gravitas in the sports world
somebody needs to take this torch we
can't have kids who live in Miami
walking around with Steph Curry jerseys
why I don't like this thing that is
underlining which is young children and
grown men and women are using sports
teams to subsidize their lack of
self-esteem they think that putting on a
Tom Brady jersey in Minnesota means
they're winning I need them I need a
News Alert for everybody that team is
winning you're not a winner you root for
a winner right and when you root for a
winner when you first of all I used
Saint Louis in the last segment at least
they don't have an NBA team right
I mean to me if you have a team in the
town that you're born in you live there
and you are rooting for the Jordan Bulls
or the curry Warriors or LeBron he and
caps it is a towel that you're a losing
player in life and you need to stop
doing it to yourself alright so let me
walk through Asian yes how many kids do
you have - okay did they all root for
the Jets inevitably come on no I would
beat them dude I would I would do things
that are politically incorrect in
today's parenting environment to assure
it does your wife have any rooting
interest though yeah the Jets and the
Knicks let's row AJ back up on the
screen if you guys can that little guy
when I went away to school I came home
yeah first time Thanksgiving you know
how you do it right you come home yeah I
come home that guy he's three there but
he's at the point when I come home
he's like six or something I walk into
his room and I'm just walking to my room
and somehow I glance into his room and
his closets open and I see a Barry
Sanders Jersey in there I walk into the
room I grab the Sanders Jersey I grab
little him I tear the Sanders Jersey in
front of him I run downstairs hurry
rich and I lose my mom I
find on my mom saying how could you do
this yes yes you know so then so then
how do you feel the fact that I here's
my phone oh no no second so we'll walk
through my own personal situation I
married into a New England sports family
okay so I could not while Tom Brady
being the University of Michigan legend
that he is yes the helmet right here
such a legend that drew Hansen played
over him just put your jets flash but in
my heart and put put your hardcore
business acumen here yes okay winning
losing yes you want to win I'm putting
my business back you're going to tell
you told you if your children had any
possible rooting interest because the
mom was into it or their your your your
finger you're just one second you're
gonna tell your child hope that
Christian Hackenberg grows into
something over Tom Brady was an orator I
don't even know who you're talking about
number two here's what I would say yeah
I would say the following putting my
business hat on I would tell my little
son and daughter and any other little
sons and daughters out there listening
right now that if you live in Cleveland
and you are a Tom Brady fan putting my
business hat on you are highly likely to
not be that successful in life because
you are not accountable you were you are
using outside forces to subsidize your
inabilities and I just I it's a tell it
is a tell now context if you marry a
spouse and that's her team and the kids
go that route respect if you went to a
college and he was the star of that
colleges less respect because you have
to listen I if Tom Brady got traded to
the Jets today give me my favorite
player of all time okay so to me what
happened to him Michigan to New England
yes right hmm that's where your legions
had to stop being a Jets fan not only
stop you should hate him with all your
might I wish enormous pain to Tom Brady
like this whole thing that's going down
clearly in New England you know with the
with the medicine guy who's clapping
this is all this I cannot wait for the
30 for 30 on this little last couple
years cuz clearly this weird medicine
guy who's cheating cuz what we got the
receiver now ban from a demands out for
40 here's the bottom line the thirty
four thirty and seven years on these
last couple years of the breakup of the
New England you know Empire is going to
be must-see TV for every Jets fan
directed by Gary Vaynerchuk I will
probably two minutes we yes have you
ever come across Woody Johnson yes yeah
the Jets were first client of Vayner
very lightly I I don't I don't want to
be audacious I have an ambition this I'm
super far away from it and I don't need
to be wasting Woody Johnson's time what
he's doing what Woody's doing Chris is
doing what Chris is doing this I'm gonna
put my head down and work 18 hours a day
for next thirty years to even give me
the prayer of pulling it off for me to
pander or peacock or even disrespect
their time with like hey I'm gonna buy
the team is silly talk so sure but I've
never talked about my ambitions with him
because it's below him and he doesn't
need to worry about it you're the man
Gary I wish I could have the whole hour
with you well we can do it if Reid
doesn't stick me on the 405 next time I
mean you just got to buy a helicopter
company out here in Los Angeles waste
the money I gotta save every dollar
those Jets are gonna be expensive TJ I'm
pushing for you a wrestling hour it's
bigger than people think you need to be
in this chair I know you're behind the
scenes now with the camera and you make
a little tweet you make a little
Pinterest I get it but you need to be
sitting here and talk about why Randy
the Macho Man Savage is actually
underrated considering how rated he is
actually underrated Richard well when
we're done off the air we have an app
only segment because missionaries get
Gary there's as you know we're
entrepreneurs here at the Rich Eisen
show hey it's a multimedia platform how
much t-shirts are you guys selling what
do you mean t-shirts okay I have a
business idea for you you come up like
every show should pick the funniest
thing said yes convert into a t-shirt in
real time sold on Shopify
I think you guys could be make it four
to seven million in revenue maybe that's
why DP shows been doing it for a while
you know okay so Mike del to fo wasn't
for some reason said a word are you
feeling all right I'm fine he's
listening he's enjoying Mike what do you
think exactly I'm a top three guest
all-time right where are you from Jersey
yeah Livingston oh my god I love
Livingston yeah and that's a Masshole
over there who's been listening to
everybody it's funny he's got the Browns
helmet that Syracuse respect the funny
thing let me jump to the Browns real
quick a no running a time the biggest
reason I think Donald's gonna go to the
Hall of Fame is cuz the Browns passed on
him it's mutlaq as a Jets fan by the way
I will take that bet darn old Hall of
Fame right now you think you know yes
I'll take that bet well fine I'll take
it anyway because now it's filmed
forever you have to make me GM of the
Jets when you own the team no Thursday
that's a Manchurian general manager
candidate over there Gary thanks for
coming to have me guys thank you Gary V
everywhere on social silent ease the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience